I tell you what is love
hatred so you know what is love there's
no point yes but that's your explanation
no you just explained it you just told
us you just told us love is not hatred
so you know is love so you saying that
Allah is a loving God Allah
has Allah you say Allah love those who
deserve his love cuz we don't say like
Christians he loves everything no we
don't believe Allah loves everything
Allah hates disbelievers but Allah loves
good for these Believers because someone
who curs a disbeliever curses Allah I'm
asking because you said
has attribute of Love yeah I'm asking
because previously you said that uh
Muslims they love Jesus but not the way
Christians love Jesus correct worship
yeah they worship him
so what is this uh when you say that you
love Jesus what do you mean by that well
love you know brother if you do you love
your wife I don't have a wife you love
your mother yes I love what do you mean
you love your mother it means that I
have a care and appreciation for the
things that he said that I like to keep
his States so you know asking me okay so
how can you say that you will love Jes
Jesus but you don't love his
Commandments or you or you don't
appreciate where he was leading you to
to tell you where his command tell you
why that's a good question because I
love Jesus and I love his Commandments
but I don't follow Paul and Mark and
Luke and John Matthew that's it that's
so fair enough because because uh
because Luke and Matthew John and Paul
they are tell us what Jesus said and we
know even Luke and John Matthew the New
Testament we cannot trace it back to
Jesus you know we don't know what really
Jesus said to that's not that's not the
point I'm making that's the point I'm
making okay but what I'm trying to focus
is on love
because because but but there is a
difference this is what I'm trying to
get at no you
say you said if you love someone
appreciates Commandments exactly no
doubt about that because I believe Jesus
came with in and from my belief from my
belief is belief to believe in his
Commandments and to believe that the
command was the best okay however I
don't believe the the new New Testament
what ever said about Jesus so when I
reject what has been said about Jesus in
the New Testament I'm not rejecting what
Jesus said I'm rejecting what the people
claiming that Jesus said I hope that is
clear it is
clear the thing is so do you believe
Jesus
God yes okay so you believe Jesus to be
God yes okay so the question that we be
discuss I mean the matter that we be
discussing here no discuss love brother
I discuss love with my wife not with you
yes but
what it is we
know keep stat keeping the Comm sh yes
caral love it's not a fake love no no
it's it's not only carnal Love Flesh
love also love and appreciation for the
things that people say okay if you if
you love your mother command exactly so
you love your parents so you obey the
Commandments you're they say so this is
way you're loving them but not all the
time anyway you're right generally
speaking generally speaking so what I'm
trying to get at is that you say that
yes you do love Jesus not about the
flesh but about the Commandments but
then you also say that Allah says that
you should fight fight your your
disbelievers and fight and fight and and
and fight no that I'm trying to remember
mistake no no you said it earlier yeah
but the Muslims they can't understand it
you're not Muslim so for the because I
was speaking to a Muslim so in Islam we
fight those who fight us and because
Allah told us in the Quran he
categorized the non-believers
disbelievers into two c
Allah
said Allah
does I going to translate that's the
beauty of Quran that's what qu has been
preserved because we still recite in its
original language so Allah said Allah
does not forbid you to deal justly and
kindly with those who never fight
against you because of your religion yes
but then that's against what Jesus says
because Jesus says love your enem yeah
but I don't believe Jesus said that
that's a problem that's the point here
is okay Jesus said love your enemy okay
who is more loving Jesus or the father
they are both love same yeah so when the
father in the Old Testament said to kill
babies and and S to the baby did he say
that Samuel here I show you Samuel he
said it he said it also in in the book
of act said so you know where is yes
okay so when step by
step step by step to understand see
respectful Guy what's your name I never
C your name Livingston Livingston my
name where you from Livingston you don't
mind uh I'm from around here okay you
not from around here but they no one
around here from planet Earth planet
Earth okay Planet all right no problem
Algeria proud of it very very nice
country Algeria have you been there I've
been there very nice country northc are
you sure I'm
five would a be my friend and that
didn't bring Bible with me okay but it's
okay beautiful country looks like some
places look
like I don't know to say this name you
hav been Wan my cityan beautiful
the
capital it looks like you in Italy
sometime yeah you're right there's some
buildings yes you're right what we say
to you look here just go back to the
point the point here is that you said
when I said to you about loving you
tried to say Prophet Muhammad about
killing the baby no you have to let me
finish you have to let me finish you
said Prophet Muhammad or Allah is not
loving because he said to fight against
the enemies yes and Jesus said to love
your enemies so therefore Prophet
Muhammad
they cannot be loving because they said
fight against your enemies but you have
the same thing when the father who you
said to me he has the same love as Jesus
he said in the Old Testament to kill
enemies yes but also Jesus also says to
forgive those who trespass against Allah
said the Quan as Allah said Allah said
let me get the
verse if you forgive and Overlook that's
much better I tell this Prophet
Muhammad prophet Muhammad once he was
laying down under the tree and he hung
his sword it was in the time of War yeah
had a war with qur so one of qur came
and he found Prophet Muhammad laying
down sleeping he picked up the store and
he woke him up and said oh Muhammad
who's going to save you now muham is not
scared Allah will save you if he was a
liar he begging because he knows he's a
li against Allah but he knows Allah is
with him he said Allah will save me what
happened the master shaken sword
Muhammad pick up the sword he said
who's going to save you now say oh
mammad you're generous son of generous
he said go
walk beautiful story not kill people no
not all the time otherwise you have to
so sometimes okay to kill people yes you
believe that in the Bible too no I don't
because I don't follow the Old Testament
I follow the
newest I'm not saying you follow or not
when God said to kill babies and enemies
was that right or wrong God never said
kill anyone yeah I show you in MO God
said to Moses go kill here
I'm going to
show gave Commandments to mes no no no
no not only ten
commandments God gave 10 commandments to
Moses th shall not kill however even the
Jews sometimes they interpret that as
shall not murder so maybe it's open to
interpretation no no no I'm going to
show you clearly when God spoke to Moses
to kill okay to
kill here he said in the in the book of
um the yes
so he said he said it he said I think
it's theonomy 10 I think he said that if
you take your flesh and go and give it
let me know you got
theonomy 18 I'm not arguing against you
right let me understand your point Sor
no it's notation he said to kill because
you would like for it to mean that yes
going kill but then you also also do not
uh wait wait before you explain it you
can't take things out of context
out of context because God one of the
things that he has in New Old Testament
is being sarcastic
sarcastic was Jing around yes he was
come on
man doing Jesus you're doing Jesus Jesus
Jesus doing Jesus adding okay you're
inserting your own meaning into the text
don't
believe said
believe
step by step your right step but how
come canot have an option to also
understand what the book says way I'll
tell you why do you know why because yes
there is some ver in the Quran when
Allah
said Allah will say to this believer why
not recite the
Arabic I don't speak
Arab have wa yeah fure list listen Allah
said I'm going to translate Allah said
taste the punishment you are The
Honorable person here you can say is
sarcastic because how taste but not
joking around God does not joke around
cuz to be sastic doesn't mean going run
me just to make someone so saying so you
are
saying what that what that says is
Accord to your understanding no one else
understanding I'm going to read it when
you go to war against your enemies and
you see horses and chariots and army
greater than yours do not be afraid of
them because the Lord your God who
brought you out of Egypt will be with
you so God is with them where in a war
okay yes the same way that he parted the
oan he has also the power to protect
people without them having to move their
hands to go and kill people God doesn't
contradict himself so he said to kill
them no he didn't okay let me read let
other people judge otherwise you are
saying to the Bible is lying against God
the Bible is true then not to you is
true not to me no but you reading that
as true for you but you believe it is
true no do you believe it's true or not
I believe it is true me do you believe
it's true you believe it's true to
me I tell you why I tell you why because
you try to utilize a double standard how
you Tred to claim Prophet Muhammad
because he F enemies let me let meish
have let
meish brother I'm not your wife Go
Married To Love Too Much no love love is
also I think you need some love you know
you need to get married love is also
theong I
have do you love your wife if you
disobey her brother you have
father question and you are trying to
mix those things I tell you one thing is
caral love the love of the and the other
one is the love for the flesh because
love is a concept that you cannot find
in let me read however in the city of
the nation Lord you wait the one I'm
looking for when you will you lay Siege
to a city for a long time fight against
It capture it don't destroy his tree
that
God
bro that's not what God is
saying mes no when you go to war and get
that's Moses speak no it's God it's God
commandment anyway ladies and gentlemen
out there is not speaking here it's
Moses okay I'll show you it's God watch
no it's not it's Moses I'm going to no
no I'm going to show you it's God it's
Moses no no no no no no no no no I'm
going to show you it's God it's God okay
I'm going to show you is
God watch this when the cities of the
nation the Lord your God is given you as
inheritance do not live alive anything
that brief anything that brief even the
bird killed them even ant killed them
even a man killed them even who's saying
that God who's saying that and now he's
going to justify mes take care of
yourself you're honest person you know
I'm walking away read the Bible yes
because you're honest person no no the
people out there then the non
Christian the Christian out there they
will Jud that it's MES that is saying
that it's not God and you say no it's
God so the Bible was G so the T God
never appeared to go God never appeared
to Moses spoke to him directly okay so
go God never spoke to Moses it did
appear to him yes but not in that take
care of
yourself
Allah you just lied you said God never
spoke to Moses then you said God spoke
to Moses brother have you today you said
the Holy Spirit you you said you said FR
of the camera to Moses you said he said
no your own words your own words you
said God to you love Jesus again love
brother you said it yourself brother I
love Jesus of I tell you what I mean I
love Jesus and what is the difference
between this Jesus of Islam and Jesus of
the that's good Jesus of Islam makes
sense Jesus of the Bible doesn't make no
sense so how come your that said that
this
word break it down so how comes the
Quran that said that this Jesus break it
down the Quran let me break it down the
word of Allah okay Allah explained what
is the meaning of the word Allah Allah
said Allah gave the similitude of Jesus
is like Adam Allah creat him uh from a
dust and he said be and he was so what
does it mean is the word of Allah mean
Allah created by the word not Jesus is
the word of Allah mean was created by
the word of Allah as
Allah the almighty have explained let me
go back to point why Jesus in Islam
makes sense because Jesus Islam was
human being okay and Allah protect him
and and and he came with a teaching that
goes in line with the sound reasoning
worship one God the Jesus of Christian
he was God but he got beat up by people
and he was God but he was too shy to
tell people he's God he was God but he
was scared from the Romans doesn't make
any sense to any human being with a
sound resonance makes sense to Not a
Human Being I'm Not a Human Being it
doesn't make sense to me so I'm not a
human being you concluded nice I I'm not
a human